I don't go with pragmatic arguments at
all my whole take on libertarianism is
simply that I don't know what's best for
other people
[Music]
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with Penn Jillette
of Penn & Teller and the author of the
New York Times bestseller
god no signs you may already be an
atheist and other magical tales Penn
thanks for talking to us
always a pleasure what is your big goal
in publishing this book it comes out of
a very odd place a man never really
decided to do a book it was just Glenn
Beck who I disagree with on everything
but who we've managed to be kind of
friends was talking to me about how he
thought the 10 commandments transcended
religion which is a very odd argument
for a religious person to make he's
making the argument that you know that
is made in the you know the moral
landscape you know the argument that
that morality does Trump religion
religious people usually don't make that
argument but he was making this argument
that the Ten Commandments were important
and asked his atheist friend which is me
I mean that's the end of the list what
the atheist 10 commands would be and I I
wrote up my idea or my take on the Ten
Commandments for Glenn Beck and to his
credit he handed out my article my
strong atheist article too and all his
rallies and I started writing more and
sticking things in and it started to
seem like fun so are you hoping if you
can get Glenn Beck to announce that God
is dead
you will have accomplished the goals no
no there never was a God God is dead
it's a halfway measure I won't go in
well here a theists are famous I mean
this is a good time prabha arguably the
best time in human history to be an
atheist 1890 oh you think so yeah I mean
we're atheists on the top of the New
York Times bestseller list I believe I
believe so that the three highest-paid
lecturers in the 1890s you know in the
last last century the three highest-paid
were Robert Ingersoll who was speaking
exclusively on atheist
he had an also election of Robert Burns
and Shakespeare but those weren't his
popular second-place Mark Twain who at
that time was doing letters from earth
all speaking on atheism and Thurber's
Thomas Huxley Darwin's pit bull time so
you know boom boom boom there was gold
in them there hills and then you know
Emma came along I grabbed atheism pulled
into socialism and then we go to hell in
a handbasket
once you associate atheism with
socialism I'll let go of atheism
atheists are known for being a having a
huge metaphysical certitude that equals
are mirrors that of the most fervent
believers yet in your book I mean you
start your credo is about how you say I
mean the most important phrases I don't
know well yeah I really see that that
whole idea that atheists have have
certainty is I believe a complete myth I
know the hardcore atheists you know I
know Dawkins
I know Hitchens you know I know Harris I
know Denon you know I know the guys and
I've never heard any of them say that
they are certain there's no God they say
they don't believe in God
and I follow the kind of fundamentalist
Christian point of view that belief is
active and if belief is active and you
don't know then you don't believe so I
have a very very light kind of anything
no I don't harbor any possibility of
there being a God it never crosses my
mind that that would be possible but
that's different from knowing did you
have a particular Damascus Road
experience where that became clear to
you or is this the work of gradual
rashes that's one of the things that's
so interesting about atheism people have
epiphanies to become religious people
become religious at horrible bottom
times in their life cry out to Jesus
under great stress you don't hear that
story and atheism very often it's
usually gradual it usually comes from
reading it usually comes from
discussions he usually comes from
introspection and for me it was being in
high school and reading the Bible I mean
I I suggest anyone who's looking for the
road deities
three the Bible by the time you get to
about the middle of Leviticus you're out
and you also might give up reading that
says when ran starts looking really
inviting yeah exactly you have a chapter
called why I'm a libertarian and not a
not yeah okay so explain why you're a
libertarian and why that doesn't like
you
I believe I say why I'm a libertarian
not and not just enough so I haven't
really taken that away you know I really
use I guess you'd say more as a
rhetorical device but it still feels
like it's real in my heart that I
remember hearing one lecture the yellow
put out by PJ O'Rourke where he was
addressing a bunch of libertarians and
said that what we all have in common and
I'm I'm paraphrasing because his wording
is always perfect you remember perfectly
but what we have in common is everyone
this room does not know what's best for
everyone else that's all we have in
common and my whole take on
libertarianism I I don't go with
pragmatic arguments at all the arguments
that our whole world would function
better I don't go for the arguments that
the free market is magic and if we left
it alone
everyone would be better or happier off
I always go to kind of a pure
ideological moral point of view and I
just don't know I mean the question I
have is the seventeen-year-old girl
who's working at McDonald's who is a
brilliant mathematician is on they've
tracked to a full scholarship to
Stanford and she is going to be one of
the great mathematical minds of all time
and she chooses to get knocked up and
continue to work at McDonald's is that
something that society has to fix or is
that her individual choice and I was
kind of in that position you know by no
means a genius but I had those I know
means a woman exactly I had I had
scholarships to colleges I wanted to go
to and my high school was very very
optimistic
me doing well in college and excited so
badly in high school I could only move
up and I chose to go to Clown College I
chose to juggle I chose to make jokes
and when are you gonna give up this man
now that your parents aren't here I
think somebody has to stop it
but really the point of view on
libertarianism for me is simply that
each person has to make those decisions
for themselves and I don't know what's
best for other people and there's a
quality in especially you see in Hillary
Clinton when she's speaking where all
her motives are very very good I mean I
I'm not one of these people that believe
she's an evil dragon lady I think she
really does want everybody to be happier
and healthier and more successful and
everything else but she knows what's
best for them
and I don't think there's anything you
can do more insulting than acting like
you know what's best for someone else
one chapter in the book which is
actually taken from something that
you've wrote out for Reason magazine
three the three dogmas that hurt
Americans most let's run through those
quickly your first three dog wants God
God God is the first one because if you
take God away from the right wing and
away from the Tea Party and away from
all of that and by God I mean all that
kind of social meddling their position
is pretty sensible you know and then the
second one is that people are good you
know yeah I mean the one that you have
here the Dogma is most people are evil
yeah most people who believes that every
time I have a discussion and I'm sure
you have these two but I'm the
libertarian person and I'm talking to a
liberal and you tell them we want they
say your basic position is let all the
poor people suffer let all the sick
people die it's the only way I can see
of making a living you say to them no no
we'll take care of each opers Morgan
said to me you know one out of seven
people in this country is on food stamps
what does that mean to you and I said
that means six out of seven people can
help and he said how do we help them I
said go help them
we viewed the government to help them I
said go help I said I am go help he's
well how do we do I said I didn't say we
I said you you make a pretty good living
there are people that are hungry in LA
go out this evening and help them
there's this sense that you will Buffett
you know Buffett or Warren Buffett
saying you know I think they should take
more money in taxes from me okay give it
to them you know there's never that and
they always will come back when you say
well I try to help people and everyone I
know that has money and many people I
know that have very little money try to
help people they always come back and
say that's you but there's all these
[ __ ] that'll just and there's the
sense that and I believe firmly you know
if you pick the person they're all good
if you pull a Ferrari up in front of a
Starbucks and say to a random person I
love my wife's pregnant I got a run in
the car with her I got a driver there my
car's out there just please take it and
park it and text me at this number and
run away they're not going to steal that
car your vast majority of people are
gonna go oh Jesus uh I don't know if I
can drive a stick
and they're gonna get it there they're
gonna do that but I think if if liberals
would just trust people to be better
there's no problem with them either then
you have your final dogma that is that
hurt Americans buses from John F Kennedy
ask not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
this isn't this the great statement of
what it means to be in America so first
half of that is so good you know they're
you're rolling I really believe and I
think there's some evidence that the
founding fathers believed this - the
government's job is to get out of the
way I don't think we owe anything to our
government we owe thanks to each other
and to our families and to humanity as a
whole but having any sort of allegiance
to the people in power I think that not
taking anything from the government not
giving anything to the government and
doing nothing wrong is a fine
do you think skepticism towards power
first off do you think it's on the rise
you know it's so I always think that
this stuff is my age you know I'm 56 now
and I think about how man things are
going really bad and then I think about
my dad
in 1971 1972 the president is crazy he
has gone crazy
we're in Vietnam killing people
completely there's a draft
there's a draft we're being taken off
the gold standard the coal standard is
God
inflation is wild it's runaway there is
a cold war with Russia we could all be I
is no comparison to now I mean
Afghanistan and all the wars overseas
are horrendous and terrible but there's
not a draft so is skepticism on the rise
do you think skepticism towards power I
don't know is it a good thing to be
skeptical towards power or does it
ultimately corrode people's ability to
make decisions or do anything I don't
think it does at all I think that I
think skepticism there's this there's
this bleeding of words where cynicism
and skepticism are becoming synonymous
and you have people like Bill Maher who
brag about being a cynic and it sickens
me I am the least cynical person I know
and I'm very very skeptical I do not
expect the worst from people but I also
think that some things aren't true I
think we have to be careful about that
to go back to this question of humility
in front of the world you say we all act
on things we can't prove but that that's
different than faith what is the
difference between saying I don't know
and why is that better than having faith
that something exists I think that
saying I don't know and going anyway
which you have to you have to continue
through leaves the possibility that you
can change your mind it leaves the
possibility that you could be wrong so
you're open to the idea that something
will happen that will
convince you of God's exist I've opened
to that it seems very very unlikely but
in terms of the the faith thing we're
not going to find out when you're dead
we're not going to find a secret shrine
food or something so ah yes because of
all the things I'm skeptical of I do
believe son Rahl was himself you say the
only real argument against religious
terrorism is to try to share the reality
of the world how is that yeah why is
that gonna stop people from blowing
blowing up buildings I feel like if we
share reality if we talk about things we
can prove the problem with talking about
faith is you hit this wall why do you
believe Jesus Christ is our Lord do you
have evidence I feel it in my heart if
you move I feel it in my heart out of
the equation
terrorism goes away completely goes away
you might have military events I think
my people should be free and here's the
reason why here's our lands that are
occupied but the idea that you know it
we're already there I mean this is the
part that no one ever talks about if you
go to the center of the Bible Belt and
you have a fundamentalist Christian
judge and all the lawyers and all the
jury are fundamentalist Christians and
they believe completely with their heart
and I'm not doubting them in any way and
someone gets on the witness stand and
says I killed my whole family because
God told me to it's astonishing to me
that nobody goes well let's look into
that you know we have we have guilty we
have not guilty we have not guilty by
reason of insanity we do not have not
guilty because God told me to and that's
one of the things that I am obsessed
with this book is the fact that not only
do I not believe but how can that judge
read the Bible and see Abraham being
willing to kill his son because God
called him to see burning bushes
appearing to people here people dropping
all their worldly possessions and going
on to fall off saying Clare of Lynne
wool blends television exactly what side
of the tree you defecate on and so on
how could they see all that and then a
woman who clearly believes that God told
her to do something is completely and
utterly dismissed it's it's a nutty
thing you said you're optimistic or
you're forward-looking you've got two
children are they going to grow up in a
better world than you did oh absolutely
then why are why are you certain of that
are you taking that on faith or how do
you how do you know that the evidence
shows you that two things have been true
throughout mankind's history one things
always get better
two people always think they're getting
worse we talked about the stress of
modern life but we're not chasing down
wildebeests to eat and not being
attacked by animals in the night you
know unless you're a Vegas magician in
which case you are but I think things
will definitely be better for them and
also things are getting more peaceful
yeah I'd be as much as I carry on about
let's stop killing people overseas
person for person we're killing fewer
people than we ever have
well that's just the sign we've given up
yeah I want to thank Penn Jillette
author most recently of God no New York
Times best seller pen thanks for always
[Music]